[Music]
grazie investigates the collaboration and the
tension that is predicted moscato drilles
nostro by the mint to the president and
where the floor after go
[Applause]
we are experiencing the 25th
consecutive quarter of growth we
have driven this year from  growth
in the european union
we have created 14 million jobs
unemployment is the lowest since 2000
241 million europeans are at work
an employment rate of 73 9%
the cairo plunge has generated
investment from the  order of 400 tron ​​2
billion the deficits went from
6 6% to 0 7%
this know-how
intelligent flexibilization of the stability party
allowed us to respond
when spain portugal italy and
greece asked that we act  in
their favor
another success seems to me to be greece
I am talking about it because it kept me
busy and preoccupied
we have given greece
the dignity it should be given
refugees yes succes  Whether or not
the results are better than we thought,
but it could be even better if the
council, as parliament did,
had followed all the proposals that
the commission had submitted to
the co-legislator for consideration a first
part on the  localization in march 2015
and another in april 2016 on the reform
of the dublin system
but let's not forget that thanks to europe
we were able to save
seven hundred and sixty thousand lives in the mediterranean we
concluded that an international trade agreement
we have  today trade agreements
with 66 countries which reflects
40% of global wealth treaties
louis moune us is to be present on
the international scene at a time when the
united states is turning its back on
multilateralism and therefore on
organized solidarity he predicts renoir  hamad in order
to establish a real desire for politicians
to wake up the mayor said ms.
rate and tried in fine to a flirt
won the votes of stars of verne
plan  etside in the form of saint
jean pierre klein stalin inscribed on
a great season
the stylists to the girls take care
of europe and fight with all your
strength and nationalism stupid and bornet long
live europe
grazie pardoned president having cairo
[applause  ]